MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to special relativity, 8.20.
After discussing energy
and momentum and examples
with collisions, we now
want to talk about forces.
And we get back to
the example of Alice
traveling to the center
of the galaxy and asking
what does it mean in
terms of acceleration.
So we start from
Newton's second law.
We know that a force is
a change in momentum.
We can write this
down as d dt m0 times
u over the square root of 1
minus u squared over c squared,
or just with a gamma factor.
And the thing to
consider here is
that now the gamma
factor and the velocity
are actually time dependent.
So there's two
components to this.
We'll come back to this.
The kinetic energy is the work
done by an external force.
And you can get to the kinetic
energy by just integrating,
let's say, for a particle
which is accelerated
by an external force
from the velocity 0
to some velocity v.
That's the integral
over the path of the particle,
over the path of this object,
times the force.
If you just assume here
uniform motion in x-direction,
then this simplifies
to just an f dx.
So, as the first
activity, I want
you to find the kinetic energy
of an object with velocity v
and the mass and mass m0.
And, as the second
part, I want you
to test this result
for velocities much,
much smaller than
the speed of light
where you're used to doing
this kind of calculation,
and you're familiar
with the outcome.
So we just have to integrate,
just have to integrate.
So this is a little
bit involved here.
So we have to integrate
from 0 to v m0--
that's our constant;
we can take that out--
d dt of this u times gamma dx.
OK, so you find there's
two components here.
And then we do a trick where
we introduce this du dx dx.
And then the integral becomes
an m times u du over 1
minus u squared over c
squared to the third,
to the third power half.
OK, and then you can just look
up the integral or work it out.
It's not that
difficult actually,
but you find that this
is equal to m0 times
c squared over square root 1
minus u squared over c squared,
which you have to evaluate
for velocities v and 0.
And, when you do that, you
find those two components here.
OK, the first one is m0
c squared times gamma.
And the second one
is m0 c squared.
So that result is actually
not too surprising,
as we saw that we can write the
energy equal to m0 c squared
plus k.
And what we just calculated
here from this example
is k is equal to energy
minus m0 c squared, OK?
So that result already
makes sense with respect
to the discussion we
had to this point.
Or you can simplify
this by saying,
the kinetic energy is gamma
minus 1 times m0 c squared, OK?
So, if we now evaluate
this for small values of v,
as we did before, we find
that the kinetic energy
is 1/2 m0 v squared.
And I find it
interesting, illustrative,
to plot what this means now.
So, if we plot
the kinetic energy
of a particle as a
function of its velocity,
we find that, for small values,
those two curves basically
overlap.
For small values, m0 c
squared times gamma minus 1
is basically the same as 1/2 mv
squared, which we just derived
here from the Taylor expansion.
But, for larger
values, this diverges
and especially when you get
closer to the speed of light.
Just to get a
quantitative example,
I asked you to do
another calculation here.
I want you to reinvestigate
Alice's journey
to the center of
the galaxy where
she has a spacecraft,
which moves with a gamma
factor of 15,000, an
acceleration of 10
meters per second squared, and
the mass of the spacecraft,
let's say, is 10,000
metric tons or 10,000--
sorry, 100 metric tons
or 100,000 kilograms.
So compare the kinetic energy
using Newtonian mechanics
or special relativity.
And you find that the difference
is astonishingly large.
So, if you just work this
out, 1/2 mc squared--
we can just use c squared
here because the velocity is
basically c--
5 times 10 to the 22 kilograms
meter squared over seconds
squared.
And, in relativistic
terms, the answer
is 30,000 times larger,
so 30,000 times larger
than the classical case.
So there's a huge
difference between
the classical evaluation
and the evaluation
with special relativity.
One more word on F
equal ma, the question
is, how does this transform
under Lorentz transformation?
It's something we already
halfway figured out.
So here you basically want
to see how a transforms
under Lorentz transformation.
We have started the
discussion by saying,
you know, in Galilean
transformation,
the acceleration is
invariant, while, in Lorentz
transformation,
that's not the case.
But, if you investigate again
the second law of physics,
the force as a
change in momentum,
you find that you get
those two components here.
One is parallel to the
acceleration, so m times gamma
a.
But the second one is not.
The second one is m0
times u times the change
in time of the gamma factor.
And that's not
parallel to F or to a.
And so you find
that there's two--
the new vector or the
new force of a particle
is not parallel to the
acceleration anymore.
That's kind of counterintuitive.